hello I'm gab I'm done we are the slow
mo guys yeah back in Bama with this
beast again this is our new favorite
beast we just had to use it for another
video in this video we're gonna simulate
what it might be like to get sniped in
the eye with a 50 caps type just so you
don't have to just so you don't have to
go through that yourself we're gonna use
the V 25:11 and a mirror placed at 45
degrees so we don't actually have to
shoot the phantom in the face
both son
be good all right dad give me a best and
only shot
see we good well you broke the mirror
yeah Wow goodness one second the mirror
is there I looked again it was just gone
were you nervous at this point I just
want to get a short ride you'll see the
hood that's right that is the bullet
that dot in front of the smoke is the
bullet Wow so this is going to get
bigger and more soft until it hits the
length that is terrifying
I've never seen a bullet just not move
in any direction apart from towards it
yeah
well I was a damn good shot that's the
light at the end of the tunnel right
there yeah you think you'd uh you'd hear
the shot that killed you just there's
like I've disappeared that's so weird
I guess because I was focused through
the mirror but you were the same
distance away as that firm behind it you
can't see the edge of the mirror it just
blurs off oh right so wait so they're
both in focus and I see the vision is
and what's behind the very focus I when
I first saw it I didn't even realize
that the edges of the the mirror were
there yes the mirror actually didn't
fill the frame but the blur made it look
like it did it looks like I'm in some
sort of weird vibe it's just one
unexpected side effect
I'm it's an amazing shot and also it was
an amazing shot oh thanks there yes good
job and good job well down that was some
absolutely terrifying high-speed so
scary imagine if I've learned anything
from this video it's don't get sniped by
a 50 Cal sniper rifle did you need to
learn that I feel like I already knew it
but now I definitely it's like 100% at
this point yeah this is destined sniper
rifle if you would like to watch more
content with this beast head on over to
Destin channel smarter every day because
he's doing 50 Cal against bulletproof no
no no I had it I can't have a new one oh
it's got poppers to it something better
than I all right whatever go check out
that's this channel give him a little
sub I'm taking this thanks for watching
yeah you could just change grip now test
in and put an and you can do scribble
out SD I'm just putting a there yeah
yeah